いつもしから出てきた人といつも励まされ
てきた人が世界で吹
どっちの方がより早く社会なれると思い
ますか
私はいつも叱られて期待さだと思います
それは上司に叱られた時により早くビール
ことができて改善することができるから
です
皆さんはほめられる方と死からエル砲
どっちがいいですか
当然褒められる方がいいですよね
ですがより早いぴ決定が改善するには
叱られた方がより効果的です
叱られるのが嫌な人はそれによって切っ点
は改善できるというふうに考えればそんな
に悪い区ではないと思います
私は叱られて改善できたことがたくさん
あります
その一例として私が小学校6年3の受験
勉強の時のことです
母が夜遅くまで勉強教えてくれているのに
私は眠くなってしまう情緒してしまうとき
があります
それは当然のごとく叱られてしまいました
でも私は何度も叱られたくないので集中し
て早く勉強を終わらせるように改善しまし
た
一方で叱られすぎても逆にそれが日常と
なってしまいそれに慣れて
案とも思わなくなるようになるかもしれ
ないです
なので励ましの必要です
励ましのメリットは自信をつけて
よりポジティブ思考になることです
そして自分自身があるので新しいことに
挑戦しやすく
シェアを広げやすいです
デメリットは急に力尽きに打撃を受け
やすいということです
今まで励まされることが多かったので
社会に出た時に上司から鹿部て自分の思っ
てたよりもできなと打撃を上げてしまうか
もしれないです
浸かることのメリット
てっぺんを明確にして正しい方向に導く
ことです
また重大な過ち中止てしまうのを防いだり
自分では気づかない欠点を明らかにする
ことができます
いつも叱られていることのメリットは
どんな環境に入ってもより早く慣れること
ができるということです
それは思う通りにならなかった時にもより
早く受け入れることができると思ったから
です
デメリットは自分が成果だと思っていた
ことは実は間違っていっ
そして大人に叱られて叱られてきた人が
開いになってしまったり
シール的ふたぁになってしまうことがあり
ます
それによって自分が行っていることは
すべて間違ってるのかなと自分自身がなく
なるっていう事があると思います
しかしこれは極端な例です
自分はすべて間違っているというような
ことはあまりないので
あじゅちゆうを受けたのかを考えた方が
いいと思います
なぜなら力得るのは解除のチャンスだから
です
もちろんの中には極端に一方に偏っている
家庭は少ないと思います
多くの人は叱ることが上げますことよりも
少しだけ少ないと思います
まずなら叱ることは疲れるし毎日のように
間違いを犯す人も少ないからです
このように環境になじみやすい人は使われ
たことを受け入れるのが早かった人でその
ような人は早くくっ点を改善し早く新しい
環境になるそのもの仕事の実績を上げたり
今後の発展にメリットがあると考えられ
ます
逆に環境になじみにくい五斗亜
力糸ことを理解できなかったり受け入れる
までいい時間がかかり自分の能力を疑うと
思います
環境になじみやすいかどうかは叱られた
ことをうまく受けいるかどうかで決まると
考えられます
だから褒められる方が良いと答えた人も
しから次にその利点を考えれば
力ラウンドもそんなに悪いことではないと
考えられます